gente dame et damoison Chevalier et
écuyés bienvenue au médiéval de
Neauphle-le-Château ce week-end le
village a retrouvé ses origines
médiévales deux jours de festivités
organisés par le Lion's Club de Neauphle
on transportait petits et grands à
travers les portes de l'histoire
le but final de l'opération en dehors du
plaisir de recevoir les gens et de leur
faire profiter d'une belle fête c'est
aussi de
d'alimenter les caisses œuvres sociales
du Lion's Club de Neauphle-le-Château ce
qui nous permettra dans les mois et les
années qui viennent bien sûr d'aider
ceux qui ont tendance à rester un peu
sur le bord de la route d'aider ce qui
essaient de faire du bien à gauche et à
droite animation pédagogique spectacle
marché médiéval location de costumes ont
ainsi redonné vie au Moyen-Âge au front
aux visiteurs une immersion totale
nous ce qu'on voulait voir effectivement
c'était le tournoi là des chevaliers
puis après on a essayé le tir à l'arc
sur le sanglier les différentes armes
que nous présente les le camping
d'écossais après avoir découvert le
convie King et admirer le Drakkar de
Roland le spectateur non initié féru de
reconstitution historique a également pu
assister au tournoi international de
joute équestre une véritable compétition
entre chevaliers s'affrontant pour le
titre de la lance d'argent le style
français c'est on est souvent bon
cavalier enfin je dirais qu'en général
on a un bon niveau équestre et
on a la réputation d'être assez dur en
Lens sont assez puissante voilà on doit
avoir confiance en l'adversaire qui
vient en face de nous on peut se faire
extrêmement mal on charge avec une lance
donc il faut pas qu'il y a de luminosité
il faut pas il faut vraiment que ça on
reste dans le fair-play donc ça veut
dire qu'il y a le respect de ton
adversaire donc le respect des autres et
le fair-play c'est des grandes qualités
font partie qui faisait partie du
moyen-âge et de ce que devait être un
chevalier
port admiration pour les valeurs
chrétiennes du Moyen-Âge pour un respect
de Dieu de la Parole du Seigneur
et d'un certain mode de vie qui en
découlaient violents ok bon le juge
maintenant depuis notre siècle c'est
facile les mentalités étaient adaptées à
une époque violente et je pense que
quand même le respect de ces valeurs
proche du Seigneur faisait que le monde
fonctionne d'accord
l'intégralité des bénéfices de cet
événement servira à financer les oeuvres
sociales soutenues par le lance club de
Neauphle-le-Château